Oh everyone I ask you in my yesterday's
video
why was the Joseph Blackburn called the
Black Death and there were a couple of
very nice answers but most of you said
that because he was deadly with the
black pieces so let's see in this game
how he fares with the black pieces
against an English chess player Henry
bird you probably have heard of Henry
bird of the bird opening the f4 move and
there's also a lion in the rural office
also called the the bird defence but
let's see this game so Henry bird is
white and Joseph Blackburn is black we
have f4 by birds the bird opening we
have E 5 F captures on e5 v 6 we have it
captures on b6
clip Bishop captures on d6 and now
Knight to f3 we have a knight to f6 and
the birthplace d4 and now black plays
Knight to g4 we have a Bishop to g5
attacking the Queen now f6 we have a
bishop to h4 g5 and now Bishop to f2 and
the black Queen captures the Bishop
Knight gasps person f2 and King captures
an sto and this King is now somewhat
exposed although this is still playable
for white a slight advantage for black
we have G for a very nice move by
blackburn and it's also what's the
engine recommends i would have an i to
h4 and now f5 also a very nice move by
blackburn we have g3 and now f4 we have
Queen to d3 Blackburn castles and now
Queen to b3 check and black grain says
that he and mr. bird already played this
line several times but still this game
was unique we have King th8 and now King
to g1 getting the King out of rooks way
we have Queen to f6 and this is a very
nice move Queen to f6 that threatens s
capture son g3 with checkmate on f1 so
bird defend this by playing Bishop - G -
and now we have F captures and G to H
captures on g2 and now Queen to f2 check
only move is King to h2 and now a
beautiful move by Blackburn he plays
rook the
three and in this position Henry Bergh
resigns because what's going on here
well he's threatening the Queen
Catherine XIII was Czech I mean Bishop
casters and III with checkmate and if
the rook is captured well then the
screen is no longer protecting g3 and
it's visual captures and g3 checkmate
and even if the white gives up the Queen
he's not just giving up the Queen it's
also a force made in five but let's just
see it we have Queen captures on f3 g
captures on f3 and now rook to d1 making
room for the King John h1 so we have F
Kesterson g2 now nice characters from g2
and now a very nice idea
Bishop to h3 threatening checkmate on g2
and if the bishop is captured then
simply cooing captures from g3 with
checkmate so rock to g1 defending the
knight Queen captures and g3 King to h1
and queen cap and queen to H - checkmate
so yeah a very nice game by the
Englishman Henry bird in the world
opening and like I said I wanted to see
a game how Joseph Blackburn the Black
Death plays with the black pieces and I
do have to say I like it I hope you like
it to do and that's it hope you liked it
and I'll see you soon as usual you can
check two of my previous videos here and
that's it thank you for watching guys
season